[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me bring in a purist
jay billis espn college basketball
analyst how would you answer
that when people say joe kitsch is
boring
if you think greatness is boring what
are you going to do it's kind of like
ben crenshaw was a boring putter he just
made them all like
what are you going to say yeah this is
what i deal with though jay
every day i i can only do so much
entertaining a nation in these three
hours
and i did make the dance aware of one of
your great acting performances you were
in the white shadow
and uh you were in high school i believe
at the time no
lines in there but you did give me the
smirk that led me to believe that you
could have been a great duke basketball
player
after seeing that smirk as if it was a
bad call
or coach k is yelling at you explain how
you got the role in
one of our favorite shows the white
shadow well that that was my high school
basketball team that played the opposing
team to carver high school in in that
episode and one of my high school
teammates matt baker who i
grew up playing with his father dick
baker was the head coach at loyola
marymount
years ago and was a technical consultant
for the show the white shadow because of
his basketball experience and he had
been an extra in all these
you know great shows back then like
manics and the six million dollar man
and all that stuff
and so he got us on the show and uh and
i just happened to be the one that they
picked for the coach to yell at
apparently i had that kind of face that
you know and it was also foreshadowing
for my college career when that was that
was basically every half time
uh in post game of my college career
that coach k would wear me out but
um that was you know that was 1979 i
think
and none of us knew that that was the
white shadow you remember was one of the
most popular shows on television
and none of us knew that all the guys in
that show were like in their 30s
um and we had no idea uh we thought
coolidge was our age or salami was our
age
we're talking to these guys they're
lighting up a cigarette in between takes
and
we're going yeah my mom's picking me up
after this you know how are you getting
home
could coolidge play he was the only one
that could
they had um on the sound stage where
where those games were
the court was really small and they
would just run the camera on a
on a dolly opposite the the direction
the team was coming so it made it look
like it was a regular
regular court and then they had a ramp
for the guys to dunk off of
but but coolidge was really the only guy
that could play and then they had a guy
that would come in
name wolf perry who who played for
stanford
uh and was a great player but but he
wasn't i don't think one of the regulars
on the show but but the other guys
couldn't couldn't play dead
did you get did you get paid
i don't remember i don't think we did um
i uh i i was later a member of the
screen actors guild because i'd done
commercial work and then i did a movie i
played an alien cop in a movie in the
late 80s
but i don't remember whether we got paid
it was only a couple of days that we did
that
um and we were extras we might have
gotten a few bucks but
but i just don't remember wasn't the
line
i leave in he i go in peace you
you i leave in peace you leave in pieces
or something like that
yeah so the movie that this was in the
80s uh late 80s
um it was called i come in piece it was
originally entitled dark angel it was a
dolph lundgren movie and i played an
alien cop that was chasing around an
alien drug dealer
so the alien drug dealer's line was
before he killed somebody was i come in
peace you know he was a lying alien in
addition to being a drug dealer
and but i my lines were i had a death
scene in the back of a car
that really brought tears to everyone's
eyes uh just an amazing
sir lawrence olivier complimented me on
it and thought it was better than the
death scene in camille
uh so it was the only bad part is i
couldn't couldn't be in the sequel
but did you have lines oh yeah i had a
lot of lines
um i got i got uh like i think they call
it single card credit back then and
it was it was such a bizarre thing for
me to have gotten that part
uh in the movie and i was so giddy about
it
like like you know i'd been handed this
golden ticket type of deal and then i
realized afterwards that that movie was
a big break for a lot of
actors that were in the film and and i
was
early on i was treating this like it was
some kind of lark
uh and then i i took it a lot more
seriously after that when i realized hey
these guys
this is their career and for me you know
i kind of just got lucky
is that a volleyball over your right
shoulder no
it's a basketball my wife is a
professional artist and when the
pandemic hit
and this is my home studio where i do
you know sports under his stuff like
that
and uh and so when i was up here all the
time she just decided if i was going to
be stranded in my studio i ought to have
some
if i was going to be like tom hanks and
castaway i'd have some company so she
painted me my own uh
my own wilson and yeah it's a basketball
though a patriots helmet
there's actually a story behind that um
when i was it was probably about 10 12
years ago um
i i was playing golf with a friend of
mine he has a mutual friend that
happened to be tom brady and his father
tom senior and we're playing uh golf in
south carolina
and uh and tom brady senior asked me hey
we're flying out of charlotte tomorrow
can you
um recommend a hotel and i told him hey
look
why don't you stay with me we're my wife
and family are out of town we're moving
to a new house soon so it's a mess but
i'll take you to the airport in the
morning
and uh and so i wound up uh putting
tom senior in my daughter's room and
then i was gonna put you know the super
bowl mvp
tom jr in my uh in our guest room and he
said no no i don't want to mess it up
i'm like dude we're moving it's going to
be messed up tomorrow anyway
um and he said no i'll sleep i'll sleep
in this room and he picked my son's room
my son was like 11
and he had a twin bed in there and so
okay i'm not going to argue with him so
he slept in the bed
the next day my wife calls and i said
you won't believe this but uh
tom brady uh stayed overnight here and
my son
was like are you kidding me you know he
wasn't
i wasn't there so i come home from work
one day
probably a week later and he's watching
an old rerun of the brady bunch remember
the brady bunch
yeah and he's watching on nickelodeon
and he says to me
and he's like all mad and he says
everything works out for the brady buck
and i'm like what are you talking about
and he goes marshall lies about knowing
davey jones and davey jones takes her to
the prom
bobby lies about knowing joe namath and
joe namath comes to his house
and he goes tom brady slept in my bed
and nobody believes me
and and i thought that was the funniest
thing and i called this buddy mine that
knew brady i told the story we got a
laugh over it and about
ten days later this helmet comes to the
house
and it it's it's signed to my son
anthony he says to anthony you have the
best bed in charlotte
tom brady 12. i like it and i was like
that is the coolest thing anybody's ever
done for a kid
i couldn't believe how nice that was and
anybody says anything mean about brady
i'm always like no you can dislike him
as a player but that that's one that's
one straight up good dude
he's jay bilas we were going to talk
college basketball
and i ruined it you know this was this
was better
because i i've watched college
basketball this year but i don't know
anything about college basketball i know
i know gonzaga
and baylor michigan but then i thought i
knew michigan and i watched illinois
without their best player dominate them
so if you were going to give the cliff
notes version to somebody right now
a couple of weeks before selection
sunday what would you say
i would say that gonzaga and baylor and
michigan are the three best teams but
they're the three best teams because
they're not only really good
and can win the whole thing but they're
the highest level consistent
uh absent that performance last night by
michigan where they just weren't
prepared for a fight
and uh big ten team the big ten is the
best conference they've got the
the most depth of teams that can make a
final four
uh but teams like florida state uh
can certainly do some damage um you know
houston's pretty good
and can do some damage in the tournament
the one thing dan that i would i would
caution sounds like the wrong word but
that i would remind people is
because of the pandemic we didn't have
non-conference games where the little
guy could show how good
uh they are and so we're gonna have some
seeds in this thing where the little
guy's way better than we think
and because they we have we don't have
the data of those games against the big
shots
and so it seems like they're not as good
but i'm not convinced that's true i
think we're going to have some
volatility in this tournament
that's going to come from us just not
having seen the data of early season
games where the little guy got to take a
swing at the big guy
and that that's maybe that's going to be
delicious and wonderful
or maybe it's going to really piss us
off i don't know what's going to happen
but i'm also wondering
you know people rail against duke or
kentucky or
indiana well duke and kentucky but if
they're not in the tournament
uh or michigan state's not in there like
is it a better tournament if other teams
get an opportunity
to be on center stage as opposed to the
normal blue bloods
i would i would say i mean there there's
a yes and no to that question
i mean i think more people it's almost
like if you have a
if you have a world series where you
have two small market teams playing the
world series and the ratings are really
low
um it's great to see that those teams
compete but at the same time
not as many people are interested so
without duke kentucky if michigan state
doesn't keep winning maybe michigan
state doesn't make it uh
kansas is is firmly in the field but but
kansas isn't as good as they've been
uh in the past they didn't win the big
12 baylor won it uh
so it i i think the tournament will be
diminished in a way
um but uh you know it's kind of like i
liken it to when tiger woods shot 81
in the uh in the british open in that
horrible weather that one year
um there was it was compelling it was
compelling to watch that
and i think it would be compelling even
to watch these teams struggle
if they're not as good um but but i
don't think we're gonna
i mean we're clearly not gonna have
kentucky there's no way they're gonna
they're gonna win their tournament to
pull this out
uh and we're probably we're it's 50 50
whether we have duke i think michigan
state will probably make it
i know kansas will make it but but it's
been a really odd year
uh what kind of pros are we looking at
in the tournament
future pro uh well we've got some really
good ones like kate cunningham oklahoma
state i think they're gonna make it even
though they're they're under
a uh a one-year postseason ban
um it's really bizarre from that whole
fbi thing that the most
minimal of of issues got them a
post-season ban but it's under appeal
and if the as odd as it sounds if the
appeals committee doesn't hear and rule
on the appeal by the tournament oklahoma
state's going to play
kade cunningham's going to be the first
pick okay we had 40 the other night in a
game like
against oklahoma he's the real deal he's
really good uh jalen suggs of gonzaga
another sort of one and done player um
and everybody seems to
be okay with one and done when it's a
gonzaga they just don't like
you know it's so weird like you know he
goes
and he's a great kid but some of these
other guys uh but but you know gonzaga
it's not an issue but but it's an issue
in kentucky and duke
that's being blamed for kentucky duke's
problems this year is if the last 10
years didn't exist and and you know this
is the only data point we have of one
and done
um but there there are a bunch of really
good really good pros that we're gonna
have and corey kissford at
gonzaga even though he's a senior i
think is a lottery pick
and is probably under valued as a
uh as a truly great player uh in
basketball
that i think he's going to play if he
stays healthy 10-12 years in the league
and be a be an outstanding player
is uh garza at iowa is he uh jeff rulin
2.0 different um
you know back you know how different the
game was back then
i think luca garza is going to play in
the nba um his limitations are real
though
like he's not he's not a defender he
doesn't play above the rim he doesn't
finish above the rim
um but he can step away and knock down
shots and uh and he's a really good
player but it's kind of like a tyler
hansbrough type thing like hansbro was a
great college
player luka garza is a great college
player uh hansbrough was a a
serviceable pro and i i think that that
garza will be
better as a pro because he could step
away and knock down on nba three which
hansbrough was not proficient at um but
he doesn't he doesn't get up and down
the floor the way
you would hope he could and and he's not
he's not a shot blocker he's not a high
volume rebounder
and in pick and roll situations he's
gonna get he's gonna get attacked
but that doesn't mean he can't play it
just it just means it's going to be an
issue for him
in being a great player at that level
there's a uh
a poll out well it's a list i hate lists
but i
i still read them this is sb nation had
the top
50 college basketball teams of all time
what they did in that individual season
and uh north carolina state is the fifth
best with david thompson
1974. north carolina with michael
and perkins and worthy uh that's ford
duke in 1992 indiana undefeated
is number two on that list 1976 and then
uh
bill walton's first year as a starter at
ucla 1972
is the number one team of all time
any issues with that how could you not
have a ucla
uh team with lou alcindor not on that
list of at least the top five i mean
that i find that laughably absurd and
you know when the pandemic started we
did at espn the you know the greatest
college basketball player of all time
bracket and they had men and women and
i did all that well with this jay i i
was angry and i even
i was trying to like i was not the
kareem is the best player of all time no
it's not even close not even
it's not close it's not any metric you
want to use
it's not close and look i get it when
fans vote on that stuff but
but but give me a break i mean and and
if we're gonna do
these lists like the truth is ucla
would be the top eight uh or you know
that they were so dominant and so good
and and
having having back to back i remember
one time that that
uh somebody it was somebody at duke
frankly that that
and it was while laitner and grant hill
and bobby hurley and thomas hill were
there
i was a grad assistant and somebody had
said something about ucla
about uh you know well of course wooden
won so many he had alcindor and walton
and i go okay that's five
he won five others and uh without those
guys
and you know i was really sensitive
because i grew up in los angeles and
and people always said stuff like that
to put down ucla like wow you know
there's west coast back then you know
they didn't have to beat anybody to get
to the final four and like well nobody
beat him once they got there
like how did that not happen and he won
a title with maybe the smallest lineup
to ever win a title
in 64 you're talking about it yeah yeah
i did it in 64
then then after al cinder left he won
he won in 70 and 71 steve
all those guys i mean that was uh an
extraordinary run
but but al cinder was the best player
and and those teams like i don't care
what
you know mike warren was was the point
guard uh
for for al cinder's teams and and you
telling me
like like with al cinder out there that
they couldn't have beat some of the
teams on that list they
absolutely would have done and it wasn't
that much it wasn't that far removed
from when
indiana won in 76 that we couldn't
compare those teams we could
great to talk to you as always jay we
appreciate your time thanks for joining
us and hopefully we'll talk to you here
real soon
yeah if you want any more stories about
some of the other helmets i can waste
all your time with it
i like it i like it it's great for radio
people on radio really appreciate that
when you talk about something visual jay
as only you can
thank you bud